[Music]
what ended with
george floyd's death began like this
recorded on body cameras
police approach him in his car
please man i'm not gonna shoot you step
on face away
it was as he was led to the police car
that it turned into a struggle
shown to the jury for the first time
more body camera footage
not from officer derek shoving visible
here in the bottom right
we all know what happened next
watching it all again was clearly
emotional for this witness
he confronted officer chauvin once it
was all over
it is the first time we've heard derek
chauvin's explanation
why did you feel the need to talk to mr
chavin
because what i watched was wrong
and did you feel it was important to
tell him that
yes ma'am earlier we'd seen images of
george floyd inside the shop where
he'd appeared under the influence and
paid with a counterfeit banknote
the cashier said he now regretted
raising the alarm
we saw you standing there with your
hands on your head for a while correct
great what was going through your mind
during that time period
uh disbelief thank god
okay why guilt um if i would have just
not taken the bill this could have been
avoided
the story of that day is what this trial
is all about 10 months on where it all
happened is now a shrine
as america relives the last moments of
george floyd's life
greg milam sky news minneapolis